mich hat heute etwas gefreut ich ändere
mich ja meistens aber heute heute hat
mich etwas gefreut und zwar die
vermutlich letzte rede von angela merkel
im bundestag ich habe ja oft mit angela
merkel gehadert in der krone erklärte
und oft habe ich sie kritisiert und
gesagt die 16 jahre die waren wirklich
zu lang und ich würde auch nicht ganz
von meiner meinung abtreten die
journalisten kommen ja auch zum
kritisieren und nicht zum applaudieren
deswegen ist das genau richtig aber
falscher als ich sie sah so stehen
gesehen habe in der herzkammer der
demokratie und wie sie dann die
richtigen worte fand die sie vor einem
linksruck warnte und wie sie dann bei
den widersacher die ihren sword die
ganze zeit fallen wollten sagte ich sage
doch nur die wahrheit sie hat mich an
die kanzlerin erinnert mit der erwachsen
geworden wenn die kanzlerin ich
bewundert habe der euro krise für europa
stand die ein garant für europäische
stabilität war und auch ist ich könnte
jetzt auch kritikpunkte bringen corona
krise flüchtlingskrise das möchte hier
heute abend nicht ich möchte heute abend
meine zeit nutzen um danke zu sagen
danke angela merkel herzlichen dank für
die letzten 16 jahre machen sie's gut
janina ich muss ja sagen ich bin da
tatsächlich mit angela merkel
aufgewachsen und sie ist für mich auch
ein vorbild vorbild warum weil sie nie
die frauen karte gespielt hat sie waren
nie eitel sie hat nie darauf geachtet
wie sie ausgesehen hat sondern ihr ging
es immer um die sache und das war für
mich ein wahrer vorbild charakter bis
heute wie du sagst man kann natürlich
über die einzelnen themen streiten aber
darum geht es am ende des tages nicht
das ist eine frau mit vorbild charakter
und deswegen ja auch drauf bevor das
jetzige
veranstaltung wird also kleines bisschen
müssen wir die dinge glaube ich einmal
zurecht du hast gerade das thema europa
ja auch angesprochen also euro krise
gerade bei europa würde ich nun gerade
nicht danke angela merkel sagen also
hinein also europa ist in den 16 jahren
von angela merkel da kann sie nicht
unbedingt immer was dafür aber so
gespalten wie nie zuvor
es gibt ein land das sogar ausgetreten
ist in der kanzlerzeit von angela merkel
die briten sind raus eher bereit sind es
gibt viele viele dinge wir sehen nord
stream 2 ein projekt mit dem angela
merkel wirklich auch gerade west und ost
europa gegeneinander ausspielt
ausgespielt hat und es auch immer noch
tut also danke angela merkel glaube ich
ist gerade auch im blick auf europa das
jahr will ich natürlich und legen im
moment hier im jahr weil ich hab's ja
gesagt also erstens habe ich hoffentlich
auch im statement gezeigt es gibt
natürlich kritikpunkte ich habe ja auch
offen egal ob du weißt in der korona
krise weil ich eine der größten
widersacherin wie sie mir meine
persönliche freiheit nehmen kann wie so
eine zauberin sein kann ich bleibe bei
den ganzen themen aber wie sieht er
heute stand und die sie hat heute für
mich die stärkste rede im bundestag
einen stärker als am land stärker als
olaf scholz und stärker als an der
werbung also die diese haben soll in
einer von ihnen und weist mit mit der
euro krise da muss ich ja direkt
entgegen natürlich war es auch die ezb
die den euro gerettet hat absolut aber
ich glaube dass ohne merkels politik wie
heute vermutlich nicht meine gemeinsame
währung hätten die euro krise ist
hochkomplex wissen aber dass angela
merkel beispielsweise auch da eine ganz
andere rolle gespielt hat als wolfgang
schäuble der ja hart verhandelt hat für
deutschland und die griechen eigentlich
fast sogar zum austritt gezwungen hätte
was aus vielerlei hinsicht sicherlich
der bessere weg gewesen wäre und dann
kann man angela merkel ja wo es war eine
nacht im juli und plötzlich war wolfgang
schäuble ja ich will das wollte sich
sagen aber er war auf jeden fall
glücklich machtlos und angela merkel hat
er alles an sich gerissen und ja das
ganze ding ist extrem teuer extrem teuer
nicht nur für die bundesbürger aber auch
für viele andere bei der steuerzahler in
europa geworden ja das große glück sie
wirklich auf das erlebt zu haben auch im
persönlichen gespräch und es einfach mal
sagen
das ist eine krasse lebensleistung also
man kann darüber diskutieren nur noch
gerade zb in der korona politik hätte
ich mir oftmals mehr grauzone und nicht
alles einfach nur nicht machen aber es
ist auch eine ganz ganz schwierige und
komplexe diskussionen sie glaube ich
auch wissenschaftlerin ist und dass da
da hat man das auch so sehr gemerkt dass
sie als physikerin halt sucht um stars
denkt also sie hätten ein bisschen
gesagt okay wir müssen doch nicht mehr
um die menschen achten sonst hätte ich
wahrscheinlich auch ganz anders
durchgezogen aber ich glaube generell
ist es schon so also der abschied
verklärt natürlich auf der em also weiß
ich geh mal weg weg von diesem thema
müssen wir aufs menschliche also ich
also was nicht bei der frau immer sehr
erstaunt hat oder auch bei eindruck hat
man also ich hab dir ja offenbar
unterschätzt also diese um diese
umwerfende rhetorik hat man ja eher so
belächelt als mir angela merkel reden
oder angeguckt wie die man andere sich
wahrscheinlich wenig pause frau angucken
amüsanter aber sie hat mich halt weil
ist so trocken war oder ethanol anteil
das war
das problem hatte er letztendlich diese
so ist ja sehr patriarchale cdu auch
dass sie
völlig aus einer super lebensleistung
also diese ganzen männer die sie alle
unterschätzt haben ja sozusagen da alle
weg wie sagt man weg regiert also teurer
weg gewissen hat er nicht sie hat ja wir
machen uns ja auch gar nicht immer jedem
recht machen das ist ja gerade als
kanzler das ist ja eben die hälfte des
volks markt durch die andere eben nicht
das ist halt einfach sowieso
grundsätzlich schon mal schwierig aber
ich glaube ahlmann ist sie also für
frauen glaube ich ganz einfach einfach
mal welches große projekt verbinden wir
denn eigentlich mit angela merkel also
was ist genau das ding wo wir sagen das
hat angela merkel so toll gemacht dass
deutschland viel viel besser dasteht als
beispielsweise vor zehn jahren ich würde
sagen dass das große bild also das heißt
wirklich dass alle themen ist es nichts
großes angebrannt sie hat sie hat alles
zusammengehalten man muss aber auch
sagen
themen wie wie wie digitalisierung oder
oder technologie da das ist eben
teilweise auch sachen runter gefallen
weil sie auch eine menge krisen hat das
heißt aber schon sie hat er wirklich und
auch so habe ich sie immer erlebt für
deutschland wenn man das so sagen darf
gedient also sie hat wirklich nie ihre
eigenen interessen gehabt sie hatten nie
irgendwie irgendwas sich bestechen
lassen hatten ihre interessen also
politiker da keine also nein keine
juliana das kabel eins klar will ich
genau süßlichkeit habe ich glaube auch
ihr persönlicher jetzt hat sie im
vorteil weil anders und das passiert ich
meine wir gesehen was nachher schröder
und sowas wurde dann heute arbeitet als
ich meine ich glaube sie ist wirklich
eine integre frau ist meine einschätzung
das schon recht viel wert glaube sie hat
super hart gearbeitet sie ist quasi echt
diese diese maschine gewesen die immer
da war immer das zu lang so vielleicht
fast so lang es gibt doch es gibt auch
kritik aber dafür muss ich einfach
einfach tiefen dank und respekt da kann
man auch politisch manchmal auch an der
meinung sein aber das ist schon eine
krasse lebensleistungen der uns nie
betrogen sind nie eine eigene natürlich
eine politische agenda gehabt aber nicht
für einen eigenen persönlichen vorteil
sich sie optimiert
da ich ihm angela merkel fan club nicht
aber wenn ich das noch mal sagen dass er
sie gar nicht so gern im bundestag wir
haben und sie haben ja so kann sich ja
aber wenn ich sage da hat jemand den
laden zusammengehalten also das hat
angela merkel ja nicht gemacht den laden
zusammengehalten den laden
zusammenhalten tun 80 millionen
bundesbürger ganz ganz viele davon gehen
jeden tag zur arbeit stehen zum teil
ganz ganz früh auf das ist ja nicht
angela merkel also das sind auch dann
sind auch wenn wir so reden dann sind
die ministerpräsidenten natürlich auch
noch da da gibt es auch ganz ganz viele
also angela merkel hält deutschland
zusammen das ist
finde ich fast süß und nett aber dann
glaubst also darum wie viel euro waren
an der gathe hand oder dass sie nicht
wichtig war für die stadt wien ist aber
ja ich habe eine anerkennung zweier ich
bin auch herrlich welt gibt mit sie hat
ihm machen sollte ich habe der wälder
aber wie kann halt mit putin usw wo ich
auch an erleben durfte die hat immer
diese energie gab die ba aber wenn ich
jetzt sehe was jetzt für kandidaten
daran schließt sich das thema sprechen
aber sind die alle an die das
internationale format können die da
wirklich die nächtelang durch wandel mit
mit asien mit mit allen herausforderung
die es gibt und ich glaube gerade auch
da hat sie wirklich was italien stark
ist bin auch kein keinen totaler angela
merkel fertig habe sich doch viele dinge
wie gerade mein thema digitalisierung
wirklich schleifen lassen ganz bitter
böse aber ich finde schon insgesamt war
es einfach eine ist es eine gute frauen
hat echt eine tolle lebens leistung
abliefert das aber bei dir in aber
geschämt habe das war so die momente
wenn man mit dem blumenstrauß neben
putin wir jetzt kürzlich ich glaube
deswegen habe ich das glaube ich hatte
schon so ein letzten monaten war es für
mich nur noch gut wenn sie weg ist gut
wenn sie weg ist man dieses bild mit dem
blumenstrauß neben putin ich habe ja das
ist nicht mehr meine kanzlerin und dann
heute auch der gefühle tochter gefühle
ja ich bin ja quasi sozusagen mit dem
aufgebot für meine kleine schwester gab
es immer nur merkel für mich ich fand
damals noch schröder besser ich war 13
als sie an die macht kam habe ich schon
viel von politik mitbekommen aber
natürlich auch wenig sinn habe ich
gesagt schön dass du mit dem team ich
finde das natürlich merke und das muss
man sagen als schlusswort ergebnis du
dir über damit wieder harte politik
machen und kein fan club mehr sind aber
heute war ich froh dass es für mich so
ein bisschen was ich einmal für 700 ein
bisschen zurückgekehrt ist nach vielem
anderen
[Musik]